اخبار حرب اسرائيل على غزه بايجاز من
نابلس اهلا بكم 40 يوما مضت على انطلاق
الحرب الاسرائيليه المتواصله ضد غزه قوات
الاحتلال تقتحم مستشفى الشفاء من المدخل
الجنوبي بعد يوم من محاصرته بالدبابات
السلطات الصحيه في القطاع تقول انها فقدت
الاتصال مع الطواقم الطبيه بالمستشفى
ومسؤول امريكي يقول ان واشنطن لم تتمكن من
تحديد تفاصيل عمليات حماس المزعومه
بالمستشفى الغارات الاسرائيليه تتواصل على
مناطق متفرقه في قطاع غزه عدد الشهداء يصل
منذ بدايه الحرب الى
11500 شهيد وكتائب القسام تقول انها تخض
مواجهات ضاريه وانها اوقعت افرادا من قوه
اسرائيليه ودمرت 21 اليه والجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلن مقتل نائب قائد سريه من
لواء المظليين مما يرفع عدد قتلاه منذ بدء
العمليه البريه الى
52 في الضفه الغربيه استشهاد ثلاثه شبان
فلسطينيين واصابه سته جنود اسرائيليين في
هجوم مسلح على حاجز النفق جنوب مدينه
القدس ومصادر عسكريه اسرائيليه تقول ان
الجنود السته اصيبوا بنيران اطلقت عليهم
من داخل سياره حملت لوحه ترخيص اسرائيليه
وقوات الاحتلال تشن حمله من الاعتقالات في
مختلف انحاء
الضفه سياسيا مجلس الامن يوافق على مشروع
قرار يدعو الى هدن انسانيه عاجله وممتده
في غزه وانشاء ممرات في انحاء القطاع
لادخال المساعدات والرئيس الاسرائيلي يشدد
على ان اسرائيل لن تترك فراغا في غزه
وبايدن يقول انه من الخطا اعاده احتلال
غزه ويؤكد انخراطه في المفاوضات بشان
الرهائن ويتحدث عن تعاون كبير من جانب قطر
في هذا المجال
الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء